okay the new year has not really started
until we've observed Donald Trump
behaving insanely on Twitter and he did
just that so we can now say the years it
has started formerly Donald Trump
tweeted threats to Iran Iran Iran and
then abruptly switched to asking for
feedback about which UFC mixed martial
arts knockouts his followers thought
were the best of 2019 totally normal
totally cool totally presidential
behavior Donald Trump tweeting quote the
US Embassy in Iraq is and has been for
hours safe many of our great war
fighters capital W all one word not a
word I'm familiar with war fighters
together with the most lethal military
equipment in the world was immediately
rushed to the site many of our war
fighters was rushed to the site so
grammatically problematic thank you to
the President and prime minister of Iraq
for the rapid response upon request Iran
will be held fully responsible for lives
lost or damage incurred at any of our
facilities they will pay a very big
price this is not a warning it is a
capital T threat happy new year
now this is already crazy and we'll talk
about the the substance in a little bit
but then almost immediately just 15
minutes later Donald Trump instead
tweeting about UFC mixed martial arts
knockouts saying just for a little
change of pace linking to who had the
best knockout of 2019 it was a poll by
the UFC run of course by Donald Trump's
friend Dana White and then just minutes
later Donald Trump going right back to
allegations of fake news attacking
people talking about Benghazi
threatening stuff on Twitter why Donald
Trump interrupted his unhinged political
rants to ask about the best UFC knockout
I couldn't tell you is this merely the
attention span of a fruit fly
manifesting on Twitter is this some kind
of crafted strategy what is this and
then of course the realization remember
I said at the top of the show today we
are fighting normalization here this is
the intellectual capacity of a person
who is empowered to speak on the behalf
of the United States around the world
this is the person who is making
decisions about do we bomb another
country or don't we do we put tariffs on
that destroy entire industries or don't
we
he is pausing his geopolitical threats
on Twitter to post about Ultimate
Fighting Championship knockouts this is
not normal I don't care how much his
followers pretend that it's normal or
insists that it's normal or believe that
it is normal it is not now let's get to
the subject matter of these protests in
Iraq because this is this is not merely
unhinged tweeting this actually is a
politically substantive discussion
Donald Trump and some others are framing
the what is going on at the US Embassy
in Iraq as an attack by Iran on America
okay now these are the protests of
Iraqis
who are sick and tired of what's going
on in Iraq but these are also protests
where the tactics are ones that I find
absolutely disgusting and violent so
it's important not to be sucked into
Trump's narrative which corporate media
widely has while still understanding
that recognizing that this is not an
attack by Iran in the United States
doesn't mean that we necessarily agree
with the tactics that are being employed
lots of corporate media has either been
lazy or dishonest by parroting this idea
the idea that what's taking place in
Iraq is Iran attacking the United States
because Iraqis are protesting at the
United States Embassy you don't have to
agree with the tactics or anything like
that but falling for this narrative of
an attack by Iran on the United States
it's almost like Trump is ramping back
up to justify at some point in the next
six to eight months attacking Iran lo
and behold as the 2020 election is going
to be going on in earnest as the general
election debates are going to be going
on ignorant but malignantly
dangerous in his ignorance ignorance and
his arrogance and the fact that he's
willing to just go on Twitter and say
these things so there's two sides to
this I'm doing my best again in 2020 not
to simply analyze this as if this is how
presidents say what they think the
entire context of this tweeting threats
to Iran tweeting about UFC knockouts
going back to talking about Benghazi and
other things the context is whacked out
and the substance also warrants refuting
and we've got an uphill battle for
ourselves trying to deal with this all
the way up until the November of 2020
election make sure you are following the
David Pakman show on Instagram for more
coverage of this and other stories from
today's show at David Pakman show
also follow me on Instagram I got a lot
of messages positive messages and
negative messages about the Britney
style crepes that I had in Paris last
week okay I posted a video of this there
are two sides it's like everything I do
somebody's furious about it there are
people who praised me for not getting
those flower the whole wheat flour
Street crepes in Paris and going for the
Britney style buckwheat crepes and then
there's a whole bunch of people who are
calling me completely beta for eating
crepes that I am like John Kerry a beta
male Frenchman for even considering a
meal of a listen I hope people are
kidding but if you're curious you can
check that out on my instagram at david
pakman we'll take a break I have to
Bernie Sanders story's coming up next
the establishment seems to have realized
Bernie actually could win the nomination
we're going to talk about that next
we're also going to talk about the
latest fundraising numbers from the
fourth quarter of 2019 they are
interesting for a number of different
candidates and that includes burning put
break right back after this